hi guys what's up I'm rebel hi I'm Annie
we're gonna be giving you in-depth sex
tips oh no no no no that's for this
later website right but BuzzFeed oh but
this is for BuzzFeed
actually and we're gonna be interviewing
each other so here is the sacred ball of
fuzz paint questions do you want to go
first I just really like this odd a
rebel what was your first impression of
me when we met okay I very first met
Miss Anne Hathaway at I believe it was
the Critics Choice Awards and I was like
like oh my god and I just remember you
being so nice and I did the annoying
annoying thing of asking you for a
selfie I was really charming and then
there's a there's a paparazzi photo of
us taking a selfie like this with like
50 cameras around yes so I could have
got any one of those photographers just
instead I'm like no no Sophie Sophie I
was just like oh my god
you're like going through the whole
Oscar season mm-hmm and yet you have
time to stop and have a selfie with me
so that was it I thought you were very
charming and awesome and then I always
remembered it and then I thought one day
when I get to produce my own movies and
get to cheese at Costa I'm choosing Anne
Hathaway that is when I suspiciously
convenient next question if you weren't
an actor what job would you love to do
oh my gosh about this question I mean
I'd like to think that I'd be something
really exotic you know like I'd like an
exotic dance no I wasn't love that you'd
okay I was gonna say you can move exotic
wearing a white dress I don't know I'd
love to think that I would do something
to kind of help people but in reality I
probably would have become a teacher
what about you that's cool I'd be a
professional tennis player
I would love to see you and Serena play
yeah while playing I mean she'd have to
have like one leg amputated I mean I
have a chance I'll play it she'd stop by
yeah all right go for it
ah rebel what is the most challenging
role you've ever played us I just had to
play cat and another movie and it's a
hard because it was a lot of crawling
pretending to be a cat did you have to
me out um yeah sometimes II hunted
how to do that without it being cheesy
did you have to hiss uh sometimes like
yeah Fred maybe the hustle I mean that
wasn't challenging cuz I'm basically
just playing myself it was so annoying
how good you were like II was just
saying myself because I would like prep
and I'd be like okay
so here's a funny alternative line and
okay I think I've got this I think I've
got this and you come in and like take
after try it you're like I'm gonna pull
this joke out of the air I'm gonna fold
this joke out of the air use your name
yeah you're very good at being you yeah
thanks yeah I think I'm the best at
being me you're so good and I think you
are the best now you boys right no one
can impersonate me at all no no a little
sucked in SNL okay okay rebel Wilson
this is a good one for you because you
are one of the most diversity talent two
people I have ever ever ever met you
have no idea like the craziest things
have happened to rebel and they're all
true so what is one career ambition that
you would still love to accomplish I had
a premonition when I was 18 that I won
an Academy Award and obviously haven't
won one yet you know unfortunately the
pitch-perfect miss me some didn't get me
there I just feel like if the the
Academy had like made of a younger body
earlier the pitch perfect movies
definitely would have pushed through
probably like supporting normals are
like yeah
come on but now ask me young people are
in the Academy like cool movies are
probably gonna win big fits perfect for
ya okay what we most apprehensive about
when it came to playing your character
in the hustle I was nervous about
standing toe to toe with you oh really
because not not like nervous in a
negative way but just because I just
think you're one of the funniest actors
out there your skill with improv I mean
you just it speaks for itself and that's
not my strong suit so I was just kind of
nervous about like what happens if
you're on a roll and you're doing a
really good take and then I'm just kind
of the layman in the corner like killing
improv like you don't know if you ever
saw that episode of The Office when
Michael tries to do an improv class and
he just like everybody's trying to get
something going and he just wants me
killing everybody like that's his good
oh I was just so scared that I was gonna
do that it was actually a very stressful
job in a lot of ways so I got to me or
canned it was sunny and the line was
blowing and the majority of the film was
behind us that's when I chilled out I
had to work really hard not to laugh
with you cuz I really really did not
want to ruin one of your takes but it
was very very hard appreciate that
yeah thanks dude
[Music]
you
[Music]